lieber Herr cizero eine Frage können Sie
sich vorstellen dass es Männer gibt
denen grundsätzlich kein Hut
steht ich kann mir definitiv vorstellen
dass es Männer gibt den grundsätzlich
kein Hut steht sogar vielen Männern
stehen grundsätzlich kein Hut aber in
meinem Fall ist das Gott sei Dank anders
also bei mir war das nämlich so dass bei
der allerersten Fotosession die wir
gemacht haben damals noch für mein Album
Männer Sachen lagen ganz viele Hüter
auch rum und dann habe ich recht
widerwillig einfach mal ein an ert und
war völlig überrascht dass ich
anscheinend ein ausgesprochenes
hutgesicht habe aber das gilt natürlich
nicht für alle Männer deswegen ist es
auch nicht grundsätzlich zu empfehlen
immer ein Hut aufzusetzen